this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies about six months ago I got a
comment asking about how falling works
in general relativity Bob I know six
months is a long time but this whole
series of quantum videos happened and
when the crazy train calls you just
gotta ride it stop making excuses Nick
anyway I'm ready now let's kick this pig
we're gonna start with the classical
version of gravity or the old-school
version is we'd like to say on the hip
side of physics no one says that I say
that I want to make sure everyone is on
the same page example time say a
squirrel falls from a tree there's a
force of gravity pulling it down and a
bit of air drag resisting the fall but
we'll be ignoring that air drag for
simplicity
[Music]
as the squirrel falls the gravity stays
very steady eventually the squirrel
impacts the ground which exerts an
upward force on the squirrel resisting
gravity the squirrel slows down and
stops this all makes perfect sense it's
just an interplay of forces but in a
previous video we took a look at the
history of relativity we did a couple
thought experiments you don't confess
oak that made einstein's relativity
completely unavoidable the ultimate
conclusion was gravity isn't a real
force and Pratt
that doesn't mean gravity doesn't exist
it's just not a force there's a
difference the truth is gravity is just
curvature in space-time a process
governed by Einstein's equation that
equation looks like this but put more
simply like this a physicist once
explained this equation by saying energy
tells space-time how to curve space-time
tells energy how to move which I can't
say any better myself that equation
looks pretty interesting but it might
leave you asking what does that mean
well that's what this video was for I
should start by leveling with you though
Einstein's equation outlines the
fundamental principle of curved
space-time and it's used in a few math
steps when working with general
relativity but it's not actually very
useful beyond that we're gonna get a
much better understanding of how things
like squirrels move in curved space-time
by looking at geodesics you mean like
that guy that's dating Sofia Ricci
what's that scott disick
I said geodesic let's let's just get
back to the school in old-school physics
gravity is a force pulling down objects
until another 4 stops them but if we
trust general relativity gravity isn't a
force so why on earth with the squirrel
even bother falling the answer it's
following a geodesic a straight line in
curved space-time but there's a lot of
stuff in that statement we need to
unpack first anything that is under the
influence of only gravity is following
one of these geodesic paths that makes
sense for the squirrel because its path
looks straight but a satellite orbiting
the Earth is also traveling along a
geode
no one is really seeing that an orbit is
straight we're just saying that now we
talk about geodesic paths where we used
to talk about straight ones it's a
replacement concept a geodesic is the
new straight line second it's not curved
space it's curved space-time and that
time part is what matters most for the
falling squirrel this is why it's
important to avoid visuals like ribbons
wrapped around shapes and definitions
about minimizing or maximizing distance
or time they're not necessarily wrong
but they're probably going to mislead
you so then what's a geodesic let's
start with Newton's laws and go from
there Newton's second law says
acceleration is caused by an unbalanced
force or net force equals mass times
acceleration in old school physics the
squirrel accelerates toward the ground
because gravity is an unbalanced force
pulling it down when the ground finally
pushes up the gravity is balanced and
the acceleration drops to zero but in
general relativity there is no gravity
force so Newton's second law no longer
makes sense
that's where curvature comes in and by
far the biggest curvature for the
squirrel is time curvature the squirrel
doesn't fall because there's a force it
falls simply because it's future is on
the ground that's what a geodesic is
it's just a path you take when there
aren't any unbalanced forces on you
which is exactly what a straight line
used to be in fact that equation is
called the geodesic equation it's
usually written as a differential
equation but conceptually those are the
same thing at the Earth's surface that
curvature actually equals 9.8 meters per
second squared the freefall acceleration
we've observed for centuries the
squirrel will travel along that geodesic
until a force tells it not to like the
one from the ground none of you are on a
geodesic path right now because you all
have forces on you from underneath
holding you up unless of course you're
watching this from the international
space station in which case Wow
thanks for watching the show anyway
things don't really fall because of the
force of gravity they fall because time
curvature puts their future in a
different place in space
from our point of view that just happens
to look like a force because we can't
see space-time as it really is
so got any questions about general
relativity please ask in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
for those of you who don't follow me on
social media or the community tab I have
a P o box no pressure or anything
but if you're into that whole snail mail
thing it is now possible to do that just
thought I'd let you know anyway thanks
for watching
[Music]